hi there steve kaufman here
today i'm going to talk about cause and
effect in language learning but before i
do that thank you very much for all the
kind words of congratulations for the
100 000 subscribers and for the many
kind words of people saying that they
were positively influenced by
uh
what i say about language learning uh
happily using link it's changed their
lives and so forth and so on very very
much appreciated
and so it made me think as i was sitting
there this morning having my coffee and
on my ipad i follow different accounts
on twitter i follow accounts in in uh
you know czech polish russian ukrainian
german swedish
korean
and uh anytime i there's a reference to
newspaper article that's of interest to
me i can easily import it into
link into my account so that i can then
if i don't have enough vocabulary or
even when i do is just to make sure i
nail down all the vocabulary i bring it
into link which is wonderful it's
enjoyable you sit there i used to read
the local newspaper now i read papers
from all over the world and i read them
in link and i learn as i do it then i
went
on my computer and i saw that alexa
benedictof who is the editor-in-chief of
ekomaskvi
he had
done some analysis of the recent
developments in france where the
president of france has appointed a
prime minister from the
republican sort of conservative side
and he analyzed all of that
again it was interesting to listen in
russian to a russian commentator talking
about elections in france giving us a
perspective giving me a perspective that
i don't get
reading the local newspapers
uh i also found on my radio so that
there was an interview with
a leader
who passed away leader of the 1953
uprising in the risk in in in russia
and he was a ukrainian and his the just
the music of his ukrainian is very
pleasant i like it it's like a bit like
zeleznyak the historian whose material i
have listened to and read so i'm
enjoying these things in different
languages
you know um
with regard oh and then also uh
pablos who's translating and recording
the mini stories into greek he's now up
to 49 so i've got two new ones today 48
and 49 very excited because where my
greek is even though i get you know fed
newspaper articles to link to my link
account from greek newspapers there was
going to be 30
40 unknown words there it's too
difficult for me i kind of pick my way
through them but it's very hard slogging
whereas the many stories are great so i
can listen to them so all of this stuff
is coming at me as i'm you know and i'm
able to you know be involved in all
these different languages and stuff and
so then i'd like when i think about how
this came about
as a one person commenting here said
if the
this chinese immigrant to vancouver
hadn't had his money stolen
back in whenever it was 12 years ago
then none of this would have happened
there would be no link i probably
wouldn't have learned eight languages
because i've learned them on link
uh i wouldn't be sitting there going
through my twitter feed in different
languages
uh
i wouldn't be making these videos i
wouldn't be affecting hopefully
positively other people
it all started it's what he called the
butterfly effect it's like one little
thing causes something else which causes
something else
and this is very much true in in
language learning uh you just have to
get going and learn language a and that
that may be enough and it may take you
into a whole new world within language a
or it might encourage you to learn
language b
and and we just don't know and so i
think it's it's very interesting to sort
of uh
one plus one doesn't always equal two
it's the main thing is is to do some
something people always ask me you know
uh
learning these languages did it help you
yeah it helped me in my life because it
increased the number of opportunities
that were going to come my way
so anyway i just thought i'd mention
that uh the sort of cause and effect
just start doing it and good things will
happen
one other small comment
uh
someone
you know occasionally i get comments
saying you know
what did you mean at the you know three
point you know three minutes and 47
seconds in your video
i get i have a lot of people that i have
to respond to i'm not going to go into
my video and find
you know
minute 2.37 and comment on it other
people may but i think it's more useful
to
if in fact you are at that particular
spot in the video and there is something
there that you would like to comment on
and get a reaction to it's better to
specifically state what that is so to
that commentator seem to be offended
that i suggested that he was better off
making his point rather than trying to
refer to somewhere in the video
uh so there you have it uh again
thank you very much for all the kind
words
and um
happy language learning
bye for now
[Music]
you